[Music]
everyone Bonnie made a friend in class
oh she's already making friends
no no she literally made a new friend I
want you to me four key he's a spool yes
yeah I know four key is the most
important toy to Bonnie right now we all
have to make sure nothing happens to him
woody we have a situation I am NOT a toy
I was paper soup salad maybe chili and
then the trash but we gotta get four
confirmative
why am i alive you're Bonnie's toy you
are going to help create happy memories
that will last for the rest of her life
huh come on my name is Gabby Gabby
we can't stay yes you can boy what are
you doing here no time to explain
come with me we need to get back to our
kids Oh Sheriff Woody always come in to
the rescue Bonnie needs 40 woody who
needs a kid's room when you can have all
of this Wow
woody are we going to Bonnie we have to
find the totally do but what would he do
jump out of a moving vehicle let's go
hey you gotta go you gotta go
[Music]
you know you've handled this lost toy
life better than I could
open your eyes woody there's plenty of
kids out there sometimes change can be
good you can't teach this old toy new
tricks if you'd be surprised
Bonnie we're going home for tea
but my way whatever Lou is infinity and
beyond
kids lose their toys every day I was
made to help the child I remember it
being this hard buddy somebody's
whispering in your ear
[Music]
and full of angel hair
and ice-cream castle
[Music]
ian's everywhere
I've looked at our subway
but now
only block hey ray
so
I would have done
[Music]
[Music]
I really don't know
[Music]
I don't belong here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
boy
hey somebody get down before you die
[Music]
you're kidding me he said that to your
face to my face and then what happens I
get real close right I'm like I don't
care which Cabbage Patch
you're from Oh give me back my
viewmaster before I knock the dimples
off your face you are I don't care bear
you see the new movie trailer for what
you ain't see it see what what is it
ducky but they're making another Toy
Story movie I thought those movies were
gone dog they made three movies did make
three movies this is number four toy
stories my pleasure what about Buzz
Lightyear stuff I am Buzz Lightyear
Space Ranger what is like to infinity
and your mom that's not right you sure
no that's not right pretty sure that's
it let me show you to insanity and what
do you even hey guys you got it all
wrong it's to infinity and beyond
impossible nothing about science
[Music]
you ready wow this place is amazing
why's a buzz gonna meet us here he must
be held up somewhere hey up here Astro
Boy if you think you can take our top
prize spot your room dead wrong help me
get out of here
[Music]
[Music]